und in München begrüße ich jetzt dazu
den spd-generalsekretär Kevin Kühnert
schönen guten Tag Herr Kühnert ich grüße
sie hallo Herr Kühnert die Diskussion
hat ja noch mal an Fahrt aufgenommen
ihre Koalitionspartner sind für die
Lieferung von Kampfpanzern auch
westliche Verbündete fordern diesen
Schritt es sieht so aus als würde nur
noch die SPD und der Bundeskanzler auf
der Bremse stehen warum
ich möchte diesen Eindruck widersprechen
und das auch begründen wir haben eben in
ihrem Beitrag ein paar Stimmen gehört
von Personen die wir schon im letzten
halben Jahr häufig gehört haben und die
auffällig oft dadurch auffallen dass sie
nicht die Position ihrer jeweiligen
Parteien und auch nicht der
Bundesregierung vertreten ist ist
gemeinsame Position die Außenministerin
hat sich jüngst in einem Interview mit
der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung
geäußert in dem Sinne dass permanent
gesprochen werden muss über weitere
Hilfen und dabei natürlich auch über
verschiedene Waffengattungen das ist
auch so weit richtig aber daraus leitet
sich ja noch keine Entscheidung für oder
gegen eine bestimmte Lieferung ab es ist
aktuell die gemeinsame Entscheidung
dieser Bundesregierung im Bunde mit
unseren internationalen Partnern dass
wir das liefern was wir liefern und
anderes nicht vor Werbung hat allerdings
eine schnelle Entscheidung eingefordert
das ist auch sehr deutlich geworden wie
schnell kann das mit der SPD gehen
sehen Sie Entscheidungen dieser Art
werden nicht in Talkshows
Fernsehsendungen oder sonstwo auf dem
öffentlichen Parkett getroffen die
gesamte unterstützungspolitik der
Bundesregierung mit Geld mit dem
humanitärer Hilfe aber auch mit Waffen
ist in den vergangenen Monaten seit
Kriegsbeginn davon geprägt dass sie sich
permanent weiterentwickelt daran sehen
Sie auch dass es eben nicht wie uns
unterstellt wird irgendwelche
ideologischen Barrieren für oder gegen
die ein oder andere Waffe gibt sondern
einzig und allein die strategischen
Erwägung unserer Sicherheit der
Sicherheit der Ukraine und der Bündnis
Interessen spielen dabei eine Rolle und
auf dieser Grundlage hat man sich im
Verlauf der Zeit zum Beispiel für
haubitzenlieferung für die
gepard-lieferung und anderes mehr
entschieden aber sicherlich nicht weil
uns irgendwer in irgendeinem
fernsehstatement dazu aufgefordert hätte
und der Druck dann zu groß wurde sondern
immer auf Grundlage sachlicher Erwägung
und das ist das was die Menschen in
Deutschland von Regierungsmitgliedern
die ein Eid geschworen haben auch
erwarten ein zentrales Argument von
ihrer Seite ist immer gewesen
Deutschland sollte Eingang machen das
sagt der Bundeskanzler immer wieder das
haben sie auch gesagt allerdings gibt es
ja Möglichkeiten den Alleingang vom zu
vermeiden wir haben es gerade im Stück
gehört Michael Roth ihr außenexperte
sagt man könnte an europäisches
Kontingent schaffen mit dem man eben
moderne Panzer westlicher Bauart liefern
könnte unterstützen Sie diesen Vorschlag
dieser Vorschlag ist bekannt und den
nehmen wir auch zur Kenntnis und darüber
wird sicherlich auch in den
entsprechenden Fachkreisen immer wieder
gesprochen es ist eben nicht so dass
jemand jetzt mit so einem Vorschlag um
die Ecke kommen muss und dann ist da
etwas auf dem Tisch was vorher gar nicht
da gewesen wäre sondern über genau
solche Fragen wird fortwährend in den
westlichen Bündnissen auch mit dem
Partnern in der Ukraine gesprochen also
bitte wir sollten uns nicht der Illusion
hingeben dass nur noch ein paar
nützliche Tipps gefehlt haben um zu
einer klugen Entscheidung zu kommen
sondern es handelt sich um komplexe
hochsicherheitsrelevante Vorgänge über
die wir im Moment sprechen und die
sollten wir nicht indem wir uns O-Töne
im Fernsehen zu spielen auf politischer
Ebene entscheiden sie haben an anderer
Stelle aber auch schon gesagt dass wenn
Deutschland die Führung übernommen hat
dann auch etwas passiert ist das könnten
Sie in diesem Fall ja auch tun warum ist
Deutschland so zurückhaltend und sagt
nicht von selbst dann lasst uns
gemeinsam ein solches Kontingent bilden
aber wie kommen sie zu dem Eindruck dass
wir zurückhaltend während Deutschland
ist einer der stärksten Unterstützer
auch naja aber entschuldigung es geht
darum dass hier ein Krieg im Moment
läuft in dem es ganz stark auch auf die
Feuerkraft und die Ausstattung mit
militärischem Gerät auf beiden Seiten
ankommt und es ist gerade auch die
deutsche Unterstützung in den
vergangenen Wochen und Monaten die dazu
geführt hat dass jetzt Geländegewinne
von der ukrainischen Armee erzielt
werden konnten nicht trotz einer
vermeintlichen zaghaften Unterstützung
sondern wegen einer entschlossenen
deutschen und europäischen und
westlichen Unterstützung ist die Ukraine
Moment in dieser Situation aber wir
machen das mit Bedacht und Bedenken die
Dinge vom Ende die wir entscheiden und
lassen uns dabei nicht von Stimmungen
oder von Druck der uns gemacht wird
treiben Stichwort bedacht noch eine
kurze Frage am Schluss sie haben in
dieser Woche noch einmal gesagt man
sollte Putin Nichte dazu bringen am Ende
völlig irrational zu handeln was konkret
meinen Sie denn damit denn er hat ja
bisher auch schon irrational gehandelt
das stimmt der russische Präsident
handelt hochgradig irrational indem er
gegen das Völkerrecht und ja auch die
Interessen seines eigenen Volkes
nachweislich
sozusagen agiert nichtsdestotrotz
handelt es sich bei Russland um eine
Atommacht darauf von Zeit zu Zeit
hinzuweisen und das bei Entscheidungen
im Hinterkopf zu haben ist kein Kotau
vor dem russischen Präsidenten sondern
schlicht und ergreifend ein Akt
politischer Klugheit das nicht zu
vergessen und in die eigenen
Entscheidung mit einzubeziehen vielen
Dank für das Gespräch ich danke Ihnen